It's a new year, Drew.
Everyone, are you feeling it?
New year, new energy.
Are you ready to get healthy?
Uh-huh.
A lot of people, I think, in the new year
wanna do big things and be like,
I'm gonna run 40 miles a day.
Yeah.
(both laughing)
And I think right, January is being put to the test.
It is.
But you know, okay, so there's,
people think you should start small
and do little things rather than big grand gestures.
And the New York Times,
they say they have just the plan for us.
They say, we should think small, think of fitness
like we think of food, and start exercise snacking.
That's what they call it, which I think is cruel
'cause it makes me want a cookie, snacking.
But what they mean is little bursts
of exercise when you can fit it in.
So could you, would you bear with me and try something?
Of course.
While we finish this story can we do squats?
Right up front.
Yeah.
Yeah, okay, come here.
Ready?
Oh!
By the way, I'm not kidding,
this is the pair of pants that I had to put a bra strap into
because I started the show and they fit,
and then I stressed ate and then they didn't.
But I'm working my way back.
You look great.
Thank you.
But we can always be a work in progress.
So I'm gonna do a squat
and see if I can hold it as we do this story.
Okay, three, two, go.
And this is where we go up, okay,
Scientists say even little bite-size four second
bursts of activity can have a huge impact on your health.
So instead of reaching for a salty chip
you can just, you know, do a wall-sit.
What's a wall-sit?
Oh, it's like when you go back and you do.
Oh, let's do those now, okay.
Ow, I'm not doing that.
I'm going back to squats.
My glutes are on fire, which is great.
They say when you're on a phone call or a Zoom
you can hold like a yoga pose while you do it.
Oh yeah, like a tree pose.
Okay, or you can just, oh, oh!
I can do it.
Right!
For a second.
For one second, I could do it.
Or, how about this trend?
Trampolines are huge.
Goldie Hawn, she's obsessed with the trampoline.
And they say, look at her.
That's what she's doing.
(audience cheering)
Okay, now that is a woman after my own heart.
That looks like a clip from our show.
Right?
No, she can totally do that here.
And NASA, NASA says that trampolines
burn more calories than jogging.
Yeah, but does anyone out there have a trampoline?
So I got one for my kids during the pandemic.
'Cause I was like, you know,
I'm sorry you can't do anything,
see a friend, you know, go to school,
but here's a small trampoline.
That's a good gift.
And you can bounce your way to happiness.
Here's what ended up happening.
Every day they asked me to jump
on the trampoline with them and bounce them.
And I'm so old and rickety at this point,
I'm so afraid I've slipped a disc.
Listen, I'm 45, I carried two children.
There's a lot of relaxant that goes on in the body.
And it's like, I'm so worried to damage myself.
So to any parents out there who have to
find excuses not to get on that trampoline.
I wish I was Goldie Hawn.
Can we get one here, please?
I wanna jump up and down.
I'll get you a trampoline, Ross.
Oh thank god.
Tune in next week, everyone.
(Drew laughing)
Okay, speaking of fun romps.
Yes.
Oh yeah, I said it.
"Bridgerton"!
Okay, I saw you Instagramming
about this show all week.
And I was like, should I be watching this?
Okay, so I asked you and you said,
you're how many minutes in?
I started, six minutes.
And then I don't know if you saw the news,
some stuff started.
So I was watching that.
But now I don't wanna watch that anymore,
so I might watch this.
Well, it's funny you say that
'cause I do think, and the timing is everything,
as I spoke about earlier in the show with Hailee Steinfeld.
Is the timing of the show couldn't be better.
It's, if you want a break, this is where to turn into.
And everybody is.
It's breaking records on Netflix.
It is not something, ironically Sammy Sullivan,
one of our news producers, watched it with her parents.
I'm like, how did you watch this with your parents?
Eventually I think they had to leave,
like one had to leave the room.
But it's so hot, it's so steamy.
And it's like, I think it might've
single-handedly gotten me back on a dating app.
I was like, you know, I am alive!
Yeah, you still got it.
Wow, "Bridgerton", boing!
(both laughing)
Okay, 'cause it is so hard to get me
to binge-watch a show, there's so much on it's like,
it's easier to get a mortgage.
I need like letters of recommendation and everything.
So does it have, it has beautiful people?
Yes.
And it has,
is there a lot of hubba-hubba going on?
Oh my gosh, so much.
It's like, it's Cinemax.
It's on Netflix, but it's like corset Cinemax.
And I was worried when it ended that it was gonna be over,
and it turns out, I found out from our news division,
we did some recon, there are eight books in the series.
So if you like it, when it ends and you want more,
I think it's coming, which is good.
So here's what I'm gonna do, Drew,
because you made me watch "The Queen's Gambit"
and I loved it, so now I'm gonna trust you.
I'm gonna spend my weekend watching "Bridgerton"
instead of the news and I'll report back.
Or both, you know, one is a civic duty
and one is a nice antidote to it.
And I just wanna say one thing about "Bridgerton"
that might be my favorite thing about it.
Is, one day I heard Oprah Winfrey say
that when she was doing the film "A Wrinkle in Time"
she looked around, and she saw Mindy Kaling,
and Reese Witherspoon, and herself.
And she said, I believe this is
what a film should look like.
And when I watch "Bridgerton" I keep hearing
that quote of hers over and over in my head.
And to Netflix and Shonda Rhimes, I thank them so much
for so seamlessly giving us what a show should look like.
(upbeat music)